[MUSIC PLAYING]
POLONG LIN: In this
video, we will show you
how to build a serverless,
real-time credit card fraud
detection solution
using Google Cloud.
My name is Polong Lin,
a developer advocate
for Google Cloud.
And together with Quantiphi,
a GCP premier partner,
we co-developed a
design pattern to help
you accelerate building
a fraud detection
solution with Google Cloud.
ESHAN TYAGI: I am Eshan Tyagi.
I am a senior business
analyst at Quantiphi.
PAVAN KATTAMURI:
I'm Pavan Kattamuri.
And I'm a senior cloud
engineer at Quantiphi.
POLONG LIN: Let's first
talk about fraud detection
in the industry.
What does Quantiphi see?
ESHAN TYAGI: Fraud
detection is a major concern
for many businesses
and financial services.
Global losses from
payment fraud have
tripled in the last 10 years.
In the UK alone,
for every 100 pounds
spent using credit cards,
7.5 pence was lost to fraud.
PAVAN KATTAMURI:
So the challenge
is to build and manage a
real-time fraud detection
solution at scale.
POLONG LIN: So in this
video, we will show you
how to build a real-time fraud
detection solution broken down
into the following sections--
how to prepare the training
data in BigQuery; how to
build the fraud detection
model directly within
BigQuery using BigQuery ML;
how to build a pipeline
to do real-time model
predictions using
DataFlow; how to set up
alert-based notifications
when fraud is detected using
Pub/Sub; and how to create
interactive dashboards
for business and technical
operations using Data Studio.
ESHAN TYAGI: And the
code and instructions
to follow this design
pattern are all linked
in the video description below.
POLONG LIN: Let's talk about
preparing the training data
in BigQuery.
ESHAN TYAGI: To detect if a
transaction is fraud or not,
you want to have information
on the transaction
and the customer's information.
So normally, these historical
records are in separate tables.
You may have one table for
transactions and another
to keep track of your customers'
demographic information.
But to make it easier
to show you here,
we have combined
both of the data sets
into a single
table for training.
PAVAN KATTAMURI:
This table is going
to be our training data, where
each row is a transaction that
occurred in the past,
containing details
of the transaction and
some customer information.
Each column is a feature
such as what times
the transaction occurred, what
the merchant was, category,
and so on.
There is also a label
feature called is_fraud,
which is a value of 1 or 0.
This is what the model
will then try to predict--
a probability of
fraud between 0 and 1.
The data here is
simulated data, so you
can replace this with your
own data for your needs.
POLONG LIN: Could you elaborate
on your choice of BigQuery
here?
ESHAN TYAGI: It's an extremely
scalable data warehouse.
It's fast and easy to use.
And we find that
customers choose BigQuery
because you get the best
of enterprise-grade data
storage, data analytics, machine
learning, all in one place.
We have customers storing
terabytes of data in BigQuery,
and they have the capability to
train machine learning models
within BigQuery directly.
POLONG LIN: So speaking
of machine learning,
the next step is building
the machine learning model
to detect fraud
using BigQuery ML.
Perhaps the magic
of BigQuery ML is
that, without needing to move
your data out of BigQuery,
using BigQuery ML, you can
train and deploy machine
learning models
directly using SQL.
And you don't have to procure
or maintain extra infrastructure
because it uses BigQuery's
built-in autoscaling
infrastructure to
handle model training
and deployment at scale.
ESHAN TYAGI: And
at Quantiphi, we
find our customers
really enjoy being
able to use the democratized
ML capabilities, which
allow analysts to run machine
learning models using SQL.
So with the training
data, we can
train a model using just
SQL with BigQuery ML.
While there are several
classification algorithms
available to choose
from with BigQuery
ML, like logistic regression,
deep neural networks,
and AutoML tables, we find that
XGBoost models worked really
well with minimal
hyperparameter tuning required,
making it easy to build
good models quickly.
PAVAN KATTAMURI: So in
the Create Model segment,
we give the model a name, like
simplemodel, set the model
type to BOOSTED_TREE_CLASSIFIER
for XGBoost,
set the input level calls to
is_fraud as the level of 0
and 1 that we want to predict,
and then select the training
data.
You can also adjust
some hyperparameters
such as num_parallel_tree and
max_iterations for example.
ESHAN TYAGI: We were
able to train this model
within just 10 minutes
over 1.3 million rows
and 10 features, which is
really fast considering
there is no need to set
up extra infrastructure
to train the models.
POLONG LIN: Now,
I notice that you
called the model "simplemodel."
Could you elaborate
on that a little bit?
ESHAN TYAGI: Yes.
In practice, just looking
at the transactional data
and the customer's demographics,
like what country they are in
and their age, is
actually very likely
to be insufficient to produce
a strong performing fraud
detection model.
POLONG LIN: So what would
you recommend, then,
to build a good fraud
detection model?
ESHAN TYAGI: Well,
there are many ways.
One way which we can show
in this design pattern
is to do more
feature engineering
by also looking at the
customer's historical activity.
If someone typically
spends on average
$100 per month on
their credit card,
and this transaction shows
you are spending $2,000,
then that might be unusual.
So you would want the
model to pick up on this
by adding in relevant features.
PAVAN KATTAMURI: And this is
perhaps just a starting point.
In reality, you may want to
have a lot more features,
and you may want to improve
your model in other ways,
like model selection,
hyperparameter tuning,
and model ensembling, which had
all possible with BigQuery ML.
Because there are so
many approaches depending
on the data available and their
exact scenario, in this design
pattern, we just
show you how you
can get started with a few
extra aggregate features
of the customer activity,
such as how long it's
been since their
last transaction;
the average spent on the credit
card per week or per month;
and also, the number of
transactions of average
in the last 24 hours, just as
examples of what you could do.
POLONG LIN: With the models
built in BigQuery ML,
could you show us how
you evaluate the models?
PAVAN KATTAMURI: You can see
the evaluation metrics directly
on the BigQuery UI under
the Evaluation tab.
You can see the log loss,
ROC AUC, precision, recall,
accuracy, F1 score, and
other visualizations as well.
To actually compare F1
score across models,
you can use SELECT * from and
ML.EVALUATE and then the model
name.
You can do this
for both the models
and combine the results
using UNION ALL.
ESHAN TYAGI: To
compare metrics, you
can use F1 score
and ROC AUC, where
the higher the values are,
the better the model performs.
For imbalanced data sets
like in credit card fraud,
where you have mostly
normal transactions,
then we recommend using the F1
score to compare the models.
And indeed, if you
look at the model that
uses aggregate behavioral
data, the F1 score
is 0.78 versus the simple
model's F1 score of 0.56.
So it's improved
dramatically by incorporating
the historical data.
Although there is room
for model improvement
as discussed earlier, we'll
just use the second model
to demonstrate how you
can use a BigQuery ML
model like this one in
a streaming pipeline
for real-time fraud detection.
POLONG LIN: With
the model built,
let's talk about making
predictions to detect fraud.
Now, for predictions, there is
batch and online predictions.
Could you elaborate
on the differences?
ESHAN TYAGI: Sure.
For batch predictions,
this is when
you want to make predictions
on lots of data in bulk
at a time, which you can do
in BigQuery ML with SELECT *
from ML.PREDICT your
model and the data you
want to make predictions on.
Batch predictions
are useful in making
large amounts of predictions
in a single shot,
and you can do this
with BigQuery ML.
But they are not optimized
for real-time inference,
where you may have
lots of predictions
you need to do per second.
PAVAN KATTAMURI: So that's where
online prediction comes in,
which is for
real-time predictions
in low-latency
situations for higher
frequencies of operations.
To do online
predictions, you will
need to export and
host a BigQuery ML
model on AI Platform.
POLONG LIN: Another
way to export the model
for online predictions
is, instead of hosting
the model on AI Platform
as its own endpoint,
you can similarly export
to Google Cloud Storage,
but serve it directly
in a DataFlow pipeline.
This may be helpful if you
want to optimize for lower
average latency, but it may
also make model maintainability
a little bit more difficult.
So in this design
pattern, we'll just
show you how the model is
hosted as its own endpoint
on AI Platform for
online predictions.
So Pavan, how does that work?
PAVAN KATTAMURI: You can
easily do it via two steps.
Step one, export the model
to a Cloud Storage location
by running bq extract
command with the model
name and the destination
location as arguments.
Step two, once it's
in Cloud Storage,
you will need to create a
model on AI Platform which
can hold one or more
versions of the model.
So the next step is to
create a model version
by running the gcloud
ai-platform versions create
command, providing the GCS
location of the previously
exported model from BigQuery ML.
ESHAN TYAGI: And then
to make predictions,
you can send a request to
the deployed model using
the gcloud ai-platform
predict command by passing
in the transaction data.
POLONG LIN: So with
the model hosted,
the next step is
putting it together
into a pipeline that can handle
transactions in real time,
make predictions, and then send
notification alerts for fraud.
ESHAN TYAGI: To
create the pipeline,
you can build a
DataFlow pipeline
with the following elements.
First, it ingests
new transactions
from a Pub/Sub subscription.
Pub/Sub is an event
messaging service.
So the Pub/Sub
subscription is waiting
for any new transactions to
come in as essentially JSON
messages.
As a new transaction
is ingested,
DataFlow then does a
lookup on the customer's
historical activity to
do some aggregations.
The lookups can be stored on
something like Firestore, which
is a serverless NoSQL database.
With the combined data,
DataFlow then invokes
the fraud detection
model on AI Platform
and gets a response with the
probability that it's fraud,
between 0 and 1.
The prediction outputs are
then stored in a separate table
in BigQuery.
And in parallel, DataFlow
also triggers a notification
to a Pub/Sub topic,
which can then trigger
any downstream notifications.
POLONG LIN: When it comes to
detecting fraud in real time,
what is the latency that
you get with this pipeline
from the incoming transaction
to the notification?
And what do you typically
see your customers
asking for in terms of
their required latency?
ESHAN TYAGI: For some
of our customers,
the detection has to typically
occur within seconds for it
to be effective.
In this pipeline, the latency
between when a transaction
occurs and when the fraud
notification is sent
is around two to
eight seconds, which
falls in line with what we
see institutions asking for.
POLONG LIN: And what
if customers need
much lower latency?
ESHAN TYAGI: The
first way is, instead
of hosting the model as an
endpoint on AI Platform,
you can see decreases
in latency by exporting
the model in Google
Cloud Storage
and serve the predictions
directly from DataFlow,
as mentioned earlier.
However, if you still want
to keep the model endpoint
as is on AI Platform,
then you can
try to upgrade the machine type,
increasing the number of nodes
for model serving, or increasing
the quota limit on AI Platform
predictions.
POLONG LIN: And
what about DataFlow?
PAVAN KATTAMURI: We find that
[INAUDIBLE] is really easy
to use and scalable.
It can autoscale
on its own, so you
don't need to worry about the
streaming infrastructure needed
to run these patterns.
POLONG LIN: Could you
walk us through a demo?
PAVAN KATTAMURI: Certainly.
Let me show you how this works
on Google Cloud Platform,
starting with ingesting
the transactions.
First, let's verify that
we have a live stream
of new messages
coming in via Pub/Sub
as real-time transactions.
You can view some of
these transactions
by clicking on
New Messages here.
As you can see, each message
holds transaction details
like the transaction date,
amount, merchant information,
and user demographics
required for the ML model
to do a prediction.
But where is the aggregate
data of customer activity?
Since aggregate data relies
on historical activity,
it should be computed
on the fly in real time.
Let's check that on Firestore.
We are using Firestore to store
the users' recent transactions
and look these up very quickly.
To compute attributes on
their recent activity,
the DataFlow pipeline will
run these aggregations
for the user, for example,
calculating volume
or transaction
frequency, and then
add that to the raw transaction
data we saw from Pub/Sub.
At the same time,
DataFlow will also
update this Firestore
record to only maintain
the most recent
transactions required
for future computations.
So let's take a look at
the DataFlow pipeline.
This is our streaming
DataFlow pipeline,
consuming real-time
transactions from Pub/Sub,
converting them
into JSON format,
doing a lookup to Firestore to
fetch the historical activity,
computes aggregations,
invokes ML models
deployed on AI Platform to
get the probability of fraud.
And once the
prediction is done, it
will send alert notifications
automatically to Pub/Sub
so then downstream
processes can be integrated.
At the same time, it also
stores output predictions
from the fraud detection
model into a BigQuery table.
So how does the output
prediction look like?
The column
is_fraud_model_w_aggregates
is the predicted
output with value 1
being a fraud transaction
and 0 being a genuine one.
POLONG LIN: Notice
how the number of rows
here increases from
12,000 to almost 13,000
as new transactions
are processed and then
stored here in BigQuery.
So Eshan, what's the next step?
ESHAN TYAGI: Keeping an
eye on how everything
is working using dashboards is
really useful at this point.
So first, here's a dashboard
we created for business users.
POLONG LIN: So as
a business user,
I may ask a question of,
where are all the fraud
transactions occurring?
PAVAN KATTAMURI: You can see it
broken down by merchant type.
You can also see it
broken down by geography.
And you can even click
on specific parts
on the map and filter
for transactions
only in the state of Illinois.
POLONG LIN: And
another question may
be, how is the rate of fraud
detection changing over time?
ESHAN TYAGI: In
these graphs, you
can see the fraudulent
transactions
over a period of time and
identify the average fraud
percentage on specific days.
Next, we also created this
dashboard for a technical team
to monitor the health
of the pipeline,
track the incoming
transactions, monitor the output
from individual components,
and supervise the output
notification channel.
POLONG LIN: And what data is
this dashboard built off of?
ESHAN TYAGI: This
dashboard uses data
from Cloud Operations, which
collects metrics, logs,
and traces across Google
Cloud and other applications.
By visualizing this
data in a dashboard,
it allows the technical user
to monitor model latency
as well as the volume of
fraud notifications going
through DataFlow and Pub/Sub.
PAVAN KATTAMURI: If
there are unusual peaks,
or any line seems to be dropping
to 0 when they shouldn't, then
that would tell us
that something perhaps
is wrong that the technical
team needs to address.
POLONG LIN: So if you'd like
to know more about the solution
or want to see the
code, follow the links
in the video description to
the public code repository.
And with that, now you know how
to build a real-time, credit
card fraud detection
solution on Google Cloud.
Thank you, Quantiphi, for your
expertise as a GCP partner.
And thank you all for watching.